Mình bôn tăng tạm tại thành phố Anh Ninh Trung Quốc, bên lệ hội yi mũ trưởng ngoại sáng mấy cân
lan thương lần thứ mời, ngoại trường vương nghỉ đã chủ trí mũi trái đam, với phó thu tướng
kinh vũ trưởng ngoại sáng công tyên Prust Còn và ngoại trường Thái Lan,
Maurice San-Champus A, ông vương thử n涵 mắt tinh ủng hộ hai nước thực hiện
đồng thuật đặt được. Tại hội yi đặc biệt của y伐 bên dưới chung,
dưới chỉ lệnh bắn, mở lại từ khó bên dưới và sải quyết chính chấp kèo phương thức
hạ sáng, Trung Quốc cũng sáng sáng ủ trưởng giá phá bó mìn tại khó vực bên dưới nếu đu đề nghỉ.
Về phía cám pu tría và thái Lan, Hạ Bình những mạnh tâm quan trẤn của Hạ Bình,
quan hệ lãng sỉnh hưởng nghỉ và kết chí đối thoại nhằm sự liết bên đồng bằng biệt phá phó bình.
Cung ngày đoàn quan sát viên từ bệnh của sạng sáng sáng, gián đầu bởi malacia đã tìm xát thực hiện
gió bên dưới hai nước đỉnh nắm tình hình Anh Ninh.
Thế hiện phá châu zâm sáng và đồng hành của A chức tuổi đầy ổn tệ khu vực.